اكثر من اربعه عقود اضطرت خلالها الحاجه
صيص ابو دوحه ارتداء ملابس الرجال حتى
تكسب لقمه العيش والانفاق على ابنتها
الوحيده بعد وفاه زوجها هي سيده من صعيد
مصر ظهرت العامه في صوره رجل لتتجنب
المضايقات في مجتمع لا يقبل فيه البعض عمل
المراه عامله الحاجه سيصه في اعمال شاقه
مثل حمل الطوب مسح الاحذيه واليوم تعود
قصتها للاضواء هذه المره في ازمه مرتقبه
الفنانه منى زكي اعلنت نسيت شخصيه الحاجه
سيسه في مسلسل تحت الوصايه بينما توقع
جمهور تقدم الفنانه روجينا نفس الدور في
مسلسل سته هم بعد طرح البرومو للعمل
المنتظر صدوره في رمضان المقبل
انهم لم يطلبوا موافقتها وتطالب بمليون
جنيه مقابل محاكاه قصتها هددت حتى باللجوء
الى القضاء في حال عدم الرجوع اليها قبل
اطلاق الاعمال الفنيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في حد تواصل معاكي من
العاملين في المسلسل المحكمه
[تصفيق]
ايه دلوقتي بس عايزين نفهم انت عايزه ايه
عايزه يجو لعندك
دوري دوري
المسلسل وقالوا لك يا حاجه احنا عايزين
نقلد شخصيتك توافقي
ما توافقيش بكل الاحوال
لا ولا اي واحد ولا حاجه
الموضوع من الاساس يعني دي قصتك جميله
الرئيس السيسي كرمك وقبلك يعني كل الناس
فخوره فيك باللي عملتيه كل حياتك وانت ليه
ليه رافضه
الرئيس السيسي قبل الفتاح
عشان نحن نقول للناس انت مين وقصتك يعني
الي عدت الى السطح دلوقتي يعني انت ليه
قررتي تلبسي لبس رجاله كل حياتك
طب مش ممكن يا حاجه القصه اللي صارت معاك
يعني تفتحها بوجهك وتديكي فلوس كبيره لو
رفعت الموضوع للقضاء
شيرين
[موسيقى]
مش الفنانه شيرين يعني في روجينا والفنانه
منى زكي شكرا لك من الاقصر الحجه